bonjour à tous aujourd'hui enfin concept
de vidéo que vous n'avez pas l'habitude
de voir sur ma chaîne tchèque morgan vs
1 youtuber qualitatif avec fiona déjà
fait deux vidéos sur sa croix prochain
exactement en effet le caviar on a fait
l'alcool de saclay c'est bien de sortir
l'instant sur ma chaîne et beaucoup
d'abonnés monde et les vidéos retour sur
la tête dont je vous ai concocté un
petit truc et mec moi je suis
extrêmement chaud on va tester deux
kebabs un kebab classique vous tous vous
déjà testé est aussi un kebab de luxe à
1000 euros exactement
c'est toi qui paye je te jure que non
c'est toi qui pète annonçant diverses et
achêne tu payes un an tu payes non mais
en plus c'est non mais moi je fais pas
mal d'arrêts tu vois non
[Musique]
on est ici à paris dans le xiiie
arrondissement un quartier chargés
d'histoire bon ouais il ya connu le
métro on va tester le premier kebab à 6
50 - mec j'ai hyper fin en fait c'était
michael heures à 7 heures du matin et je
crève la dalle donc on va y aller
vraiment au courant c'est parti bonjour
monsieur bonjour messieurs c'est vrai
qu'on s'est bien fait chier
alors moi vos liens un classique salades
tomates oignons fromage sauce algérienne
sans oignon sinon je vais avoir la
diarrhée alors est-ce que vous avez la
sauce ch'ti
si on peut la faire pour toi un peu de
salade tomate les san antonio pour
restaurer la direction notamment n'était
pas légal a tonné viewer oui mais chez
vous on vient y opposer qui pas parce
que parfois je me la liste des noms des
noms pour ce truc
il ya doner kebab grecque chiche kebab
les ai pas qu'il vienne mais y en a pas
mal
et toi tu préfère qu'on l'appelle
monsieur ou chef en face de vous ça va
être chef
donc sauf qu'ils comptent un match en
chef et la cave
[Musique]
déjà sotchi ce stick et sauce ch'ti vie
commune fait une grimace comme celle
d'espèces et voilà source algérienne
merci malicieux oil chose moi je viens
d'un petit couvert à ce qu'après bien
sûr messieurs tout genre de métro moi je
suis un bon joueur mais du coup c'est
vraiment une source ultime c'est de la
mayo en fait tu m'as bien [ __ ] la fois
bien et pierre mais c'est quoi ce jeudi
matin
moi je regardais dans la france un
million de malades par exprès et dans le
nord est achevée dans une friterie parce
que c'est grâce à la baraka le tabac
était vraiment d'assaut ce marquage qui
voir ce qu'est bam
on sait bien s'effondrer abonde siens
ouais c'est moi le méga moi j'ai un
c'est un plaisir je me régale les
meilleurs clubs du continent je crois à
3,81 tension et barbe samedi soir
comptait entre les deux tours du monde
et skoda exact mais on peut dire aux
gens j'étais un effort a dit me fait
découvrir le bon s'appelle jean tonique
je ne sais pas j'ai fait rien c'est le
gabon qui est le sien comme vraiment
comme des chiens jaunes et comment les
jeux c'est normal je gagne c'est très
droite inquiète je me suis barré une
demi-heure savage à 12,3 bien avec des
concombres de dahouët embûches de condom
et penseur un truc un peu légers peuvent
y être quatre d'affilée
car ou en train de maisons douche vomi
mois général actuel je vomis dans ma
bouche bien choisir vos appareils figure
toi qu'on s'est à nouveau classé
alors ça vous plaît pour moi c'est enfin
l'heure du passage parce qu'il a toi
confrères et toutes les fois qu un
accord parce que bon ben ok vas nous
avons montré un fort que trouve énorme
will go on a quatre qui les préfèrent la
vidéo de sa quête non franchement elle
est très bon mais c'est pas l'air bien
cherché à la sociét'halle cette idée ça
c'est de la viande de veau
ou que nous préparons 24 heures avant
sous marine
l'avion avant de la faire en bout de
ligne mais les gars bien j'espère que
non j'ai toujours rêvé de faire un kebab
découper la viande est allé on va
essayer je veux mais je me taperais
j'aille on est là avec leurs fruits le
truc qui ne pas plonger
bon bah voilà maintenant qu'on n'est
plus devant les cuistots on peut le dire
c'était compter sans la salle
j'ai mal au bide et sur un but d'oliech
totalement faux c'est très très bon
c'était pour moi j'ai le bild remplit
pas ces 17es clasico quoi cette envie
d'un bon kebab tout la cote à ce que
maintenant le moment que tu montes un
petit peu on va tester le truc culte
voit dans un restaurant qui nous a prêté
les locaux pour l'occasion j'ai eu une
équipe ça fait deux trois mois qui
bossent dessus pour essayer de faire le
kebab 2 en allemagne n 2 en deux ans et
demi à peu près j'étais est rongé répond
comme un chêne et pour essayer de faire
le club le plus luxueux qui n'a jamais
existé et faire le premier kebab au
monde au boeuf de kobé donc la veuve de
cobain en rappel c'est un boeuf très
très tendre c'est l'un des plus rares en
fait exactement c'est un beauf qui est
ce assez leboeuf qui est massé le reste
fait masser se fait sucer
concernant mon pote fait des jacuzzis
voilà c'est ça et là faire un feat avec
shia labeouf qui font un peu de musique
entre potes ils font des as ils font des
boeufs o olalalala et donc la somme
totale de ceux qui bavent ce sera
combien minimum 1000 euros par personne
ah ouais donc comprendre comprendre de
kebab basto qui paye un stationnement
pas chacun dans les veaux restaurant en
question la main tu es une place au
chaud avec de courir sur la place est
déjà culte
cemex est déjà culte
[Musique]
c'est sur cette belle table ouais c'est
très à l'aise on voit que tu maîtrises
et sachant combien ça coûte ou et
luxueux
en gros on va déguster un kebab genre
unique au monde qu'on peut manger que tu
aimes maintenant ici et a réuni trois
chefs qui se sont donnés un chef
français un maître sushi est un chef qui
babille turcs et qui a étudié en
allemagne
locke et mobile est née quelques héros
dur qui aimaient trop salé maroc a
travaillé aussi avec thibaut petit buck
et le salé qui est le patron d une
savate ibo et à fira tu que ton père est
normal que le chef qui va bien lui qui
nous a permis un petit peu ce que un
maître sushi qui fait un qui va tout
seul c'est bizarre je pense oui si l'on
peut travailler main dans la main et est
ce que le résultat est concluant selon
vous absolument alors je vais laisser
commencer donc le chef turc va vous
expliquer vraiment le kebab
gastronomique vous allez pouvoir
déguster
donc on est parti sur une base on ne
rend pas c'est la base salades tomates
oignons par pouce die pousses de
roquette tomates cerises oignons rouges
ans 8-9 de kobe c'est la spécialité du
chef le boeuf de kobé aussi est une
viande qui est à l'instar du caviar ou
de la truffe quelque chose de vraiment
exceptionnel dans sa catégorie le label
boeuf de kobe en tout cas c'est
uniquement des élevages qui sont face à
la mer dans la préfecture de hyogo donc
c'est des bêtes qui pour éviter toute
forme de stress tout simplement sont
massés quotidiennement parfois avec du
sac est bon ça c'est une petite légende
avec l'intrus ce petit massage mûri tout
on est là tous les légumes cas cités
les dix poissons en fait on va bien peu
routier on va c'est d'apporter le boulot
qu'une à la française dans le kebab et
j'ai réussi à trouver ce matin à pain
dans le xviiie quartier de la goutte
d'or un vrai mac lois traditionnelles
fait fait-maison cuit du matin ce sera
bien fondant on sera vraiment dans le
vrai kebab à ça que j'ai une question
l'équivalent ça vient d'où ça vient ça a
été inventé en 1911 par un immigré tueur
à berlin et des kebabs allemands sont
différents des autres
totalement différent c'est plus qu'ali
en allemagne qu'en france et maintenant
tu le dis je lui rappelle alors manger
un kebab en allemagne à berlin justement
et c'était délicieux quand on va partir
donc du coup sûr la préparation de votre
équipe
on a juste trop s'il ya trois cuistots
différentes qui vont furie 19 c'est
n'importe quoi mais qu'il sait qt
[Musique]
pendant que la préparation de ce fait
mystérieusement en cuisine je vais
propose de faire l'interview morgan ps
parti autant morgan
[Musique]
préval à des questions tout est
renseigné ça fait vraiment plaisir c'est
une chaîne youtube qui s'appelle morgan
vs
voilà un mois je compare les choses je
compare des choses classiques ou tournée
m6 de manger ensuite je faisais chez les
grands chefs de jeunes chefs dans les
pays du monde entier en france et au
commerce
tu as un background dans la gastronomie
vous voyez pas trop j'observe un resto
pour payer mes cours de 4 à l'époque est
en fait une musique triste et sur ce cas
c'est super ça fait un peu d'argent
public nous tiens mais c'est surtout
[Musique]
j'aimerais c'est un peu en tant que
serveur en fait il ya deux ans une
chaîne américaine qui compte par les
choses en fonction des prix qui ont
contacté qu'on aimerait bien faire c'est
un petit peu la française avec un humour
un petit peu graveleux sous sa tente et
ensuite on a décidé de faire tout cela
doit être père de famille ça ma vraie
avec le père de famille jacques bompard
la maison l'agencé vidéo c'est pour elle
qu'il a fait c'est d'être à ce qui
marche toujours
tu compte sortir des vidéos pas sur la
bouffe on a fait sur l'alcool dont la
vidéo son sac et a bien vu sur cette
vidéo un mec j'ai vu pas mal on a vu les
rushs célébrer s'était joué on était
content moi j'ai à l'école je voyais ma
part quand je vois bien la douche on va
faire des courts métrages je suis enfin
du court métrage on va tester d'autres
choses on va là dubaï avec le salt b
tester les pêcheurs du monde
enfin des couteaux à 5 bat contre des
grands couteaux qui peut plusieurs
milliers d'euros ça reste quand même
thématique
on aime bien qu'on parle en fait on aime
bien qui en fait on tourne avec des gens
qui ont peu l'habitude d'être filmé
c'est très marrant je pense qu'on peut
décréter que l'interview morgan avait à
se terminer
merci mon précieux pour aller avec un
souk aient même pas ce que nous propose
un petit rouge c'est du grenache sait
cultiver dans le sud de la vallée du
rhône hu et ses vinifié à paris pour
voir ça du fruit c'est aussi un
caractère assez intense
déjà le verbe et géant vainqueurs 5 6
milliards des saveurs jamais pris un
verre de vin qui accable tapas et
tropicaux ans et bolloc'h mojito stop à
celle ci on trouve quoi fin bat contre
un quartier neuf mois je vois beaucoup
de vent mais comme mon père waouh
moi j'ai pas les mots mais c'est bof et
à toi mais ça ça va bien avec le
canadien table ronde a besoin d'un petit
peu la note a besoin de structures
surtout le dos de koné qui exempte
supergrass et les tanins et le gras les
deux se marient parfaitement bien passé
des vins qui sont beaucoup de fruits qui
sont un petit peu corsé un petit peu de
légèrement épicé non c'est un vent assez
fort et a donc tannique donc dans ce
quoi regarder j'en doute je sais qu'ils
retournent sur youtube je crois de toute
sa vie l'a jamais dit serait vachement
bien avec votre kebab ça donne
aujourd'hui cette phrase
[Musique]
paula
c'est génial image blanche mais qui a
des feuilles de bananier ça fait par
tous a bien dû international
c'est un kebab internationale gde
transparent un peu ces désordres de
l'ain pipa moi c'est génial de kobe mais
qu'il soit classé l'avion le plus cher
du smic j'ai même pas faim c'est ça qui
est ça qui est génial franchement ça je
le garde pour ce soir là font
stationnement doggy bag
voilà les deux terminé merci à tous au
parc on recommence jusque là il ya une
pression totale sur les papilles alors
messieurs pour accompagner ce boeuf de
kobe je vais avoir la chance de vous
présenter la plus vieille sauce soja au
monde disponibles sur le marché
donc c'est un millésime 1979 donc 38 ans
d'âge je reste bien dans le monde des
sports alors ça a été sorti en édition
limitée il ya eu 100 flacons qui sont
sortis en 2019 je savais pas que ça
existait des choses comme ça comme ça
alors là on est sur une bouteille de 55
minutes et à hauteur de 160 euros
et là ça tombe par terre mais rejetant
berges de la deûle à palper allez-y vous
en prie que tu m'aimais jeunes sortir
chez un mec qui associe plutôt heureuse
de faire un gros plan sur cet objet à
160 euros
moi je me sers un prêt pour ça dans la
presse mais conditionne la potion
magique d'astérix peur celle ci est déçu
j'aurais mangé mais un millimètre de
l'autre et j'aurai des fonds c'est
celui-là là généralement l'équipe
technique qu'ils espèrent tous qu'on va
pas tenir jeudi genre d'homme vidéo
c'est comme ça c'est obligé plus je
m'approche de la fin plus on abrège
avait commencé par le culte pendant un
petit bout de viande en fait beaucoup tu
es un peu le kobe comme ça
mais
un sens et tout ça dans un kebab de luxe
souffre ce dimanche commence comme
moteur mais asie la tong rôle à moi la
mecque le cas moi je suis un copieur
atomique
cela des meilleur goût que j'ai mangé de
toute ma vie
alors à part dans sa des frites à la
patate douce un hasard moi elle me
connaît un peu moins tout ton tu l'as
entendu
moi j'ai entendu ça même le cobp et je
pense qu'on lui indique les finales dans
un kebab
il avait une petite la rochelle je me
suis fait masser pendant 20 ans en
écoutant de la musique classique grecque
donc les fameux légume cuit à la
perfection je connais pas les termes
techniques mois mais cette ressource man
tient pas s'opposer tout ça c'est ce
qu'on disait combien ça prends toi mec
je découvrais c'est l'une des pistes et
puis c'est plus cher au monde jusqu'à 44
mille euros le kilo et c'est vraiment
chouette quand ils l'ont acheté
ils recherchent une toute petite boîte
comme ça avec des cadenas et une énorme
grosse boîte avec encore un canadien
doit cesser si cher que c'est le prix de
l'or c'est plus cher que dans le safran
si c'est la meilleure et plus sûre
donc j'ai un peu de disséquer la bête
pasquale petites billes justement on
transparente caviar de citron s'ils sont
amers en fait c'est un ami ben ali juste
une tranche est en fait à l'intérieur
c'est un petit big crois que c'est assez
donc qu'est ce qu'on a connu et
asiatiques a dedans en réalité donc déjà
il ya eu le boeuf de kobé don qui vient
du japon
la sauce blanche a été associé avec
et la sauce au vin 38 ans
on a comme moi je vais voter un petit
peu de sochaux peu ça dérange pas justin
chon je les payais frère donc tu vas
faire quoi
je cherche c'est passé en fait j'ai le
kobe nerveux mais qu'il teste sur un
couteau ultra tranchant quoi bon moment
ça peut déraper stabilise a obtenu copie
de ce que tu fais ce que je suis fan de
toi comment gâcher un peleton copie
vraiment pas éléctro dave exa social et
que ce soit dans le monde et dont la
moitié sur ton plateau 38 ans s'est
perdue dans les cdi encore absolument
donc à une accroche au palais qui est
beaucoup plus développé la salinité qui
est complètement
qui est extrêmement puissant et
n'accrochant mots que vous avez manie
sucré salé acide amer que c'est le point
qui vaut ni les quatre fait c'est le mot
parfait bull avec c'est ce que j'essaie
de faire d'un gène imposé et aujourd'hui
on sait que c'est un loup qui existent
ça s'appelle le glutamate et on a des
septs heures sur la langue
spécifiquement pour lou m'a mis d'accord
donc c'est pas simplement l'apogée des
quatre premiers groupes connaissent
véritablement un cinquième goût qui est
représenté par l'humani méritons d une
culture ici là je sens large et surtout
d'en respecter un petit beat demande
j'aimerais sans oignon comme dans les
bouquets barre à l'ancienne et j'ai pas
d'oignons et sa sa balle à callao fait
bien goûter flou même tout le monde hugo
beauty un petit peu en tapant micro avec
de la viande c'est incroyable il ya fait
c'est l'équilibré pour qui est trop de
goût mais en fin de compte y a pas un
seul bout qui cacherait ces deux points
au moment où mammy mammy au mode jc la
sous-marque déjà conseil avec un vin
tannique cervin grenache ça passait pas
cépages grenache faut savoir ce que
c'est je ne sais pas c'est là où le
raisin du bon pour toi savoir parler
mais ouais c'est un cépage grenache tu
connaissais un peu ou pas mais c'est pas
mais j'apprécie je mange du couvent est
cuit et j'apprécie savez-vous des crues
déjà un tartare kobe kg ha bah je pars
vite et on a tout simplement la
structure qui a été fait par ci rate
donc calerait savoir faire en terme
d'ordre à mettre notamment sur la sauce
blanche aussi qui a été fait sur place
ensuite on a eu la cuisson des légumes
qui a été parfaitement maîtrisée au
kebab c'est comme n'importe quel plat
finalement si t'as pas différentes
textures tu t'ennuies à manger selon
sita ducrocq quant à moi le du
pentateuque autant des légumes le faut
rendez les gras après on joue aussi avec
pareille anvar de l'amertume sucré du
salé
mamie de conduite sous toutes les
saveurs quand arrivait à quoi avoir les
cinq saveurs domaine oui je n'aime pas
du tout en gros c'est quoi la
répartition des 1000 euros là dedans qu
est ce qui coûte si cher est dans sur
l'assaut donc sonné sur 3000 euros le
litre la viande 420 euros le kilo de
safran ses 44 mille euros le kilo le
citron caviar donc 55 euros le kilo à
peu près ensuite on est sur des
garnitures qui sont assez noble donc
jusque et patates douces asperges
il ya de la grenade évidemment précise
que ce qui bat à 1000 euros on a
organisé le truc pour le spectacle pour
la vidéo uniquement juste programmant
unique me demande en retour et avec les
babas 5 euros et c'est très bien les
mecs mais c'est ça ça ces nouvelles
majeures la vigne et ouais si les mecs
pour les violences les traits en 2d
comme morbide bas messieurs merci pour
ce moment culte franchement c'était
juste délicieux ne se régaler j'avais
mangé ses produits de toute ma vie que
je pense que mes ovaires sont
extrêmement fins actuellement il voit
jamais des divisions comme ça sur ma
chaîne donc c'est une petite prière peu
exclusif donc c'est cool attitude est
réuni pour sal avoir pris du temps pour
ce montant est à merci morgan quel grand
plaisir même si c'est un grand plaisir
au travail avait rien là mais on a déjà
fait trois vidéos ensemble comment fera
une seizième l'occasion voiture sur la
chaise du coup s'appelait comment jouer
mais que je dois vous faire passer en
force a remarqué je suis de plus en plus
gros et je ne compte pas m'arrêter en si
bon chemin
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo j'espère
vous n'êtes pas trop affamés suivez la
chaîne de morgane vs allez mange au
restaurant des différents chefs ici
présent on met tous à la description et
nous on se revoit pour des vidéos un peu
plus classique très prochainement restez
connectés
vous en voulez encore alors cliquez ici
pour voir la vidéo on teste du sac et
sur la chaîne de morgane ds avec que
marc hugo et plein de gens dont j'ai
oublié le prénom
ils sont super sympas mais bien sûr
cette vidéo est déjà culte mon pote et
c'est toi qui le dit bannon la sto qui
l'a dit du coup mais bah non je ne sais
pas quoi dire c'est pour ça excuse moi
non mais après si ça va qu'est ce qu'il
ya au negro c'est un métier mais ce que
je voudrais je suis du mange des plats
c'est tout